hello and we're glad you've joined us
for this live webinar how to maximize
tumor microenvironment analysis from
limited patient samples I'm Suzy Valdez
of lab routes and I'll be moderating
this session today's educational web
seminar is presented by lab routes the
leading scientific social networking
website and provider of virtual events
and webinars advancing scientific
collaboration and learning it's also
brought to you by Milton E biotech to
learn more about Milton a biotech visit
them at their website WWL tonight
biotech comm so let's get started you
can pose questions to the speaker during
the presentation while they're fresh in
your mind to do so just simply type them
into the drop down box located on the
far left of your screen labeled ask a
question and click that send button
questions will be answered after the
presentation to enlarge the slide window
click on the arrows at the top right
hand corner of your presentation window
if you experience any technical problems
like seeing or hearing the presentation
simply click on the support tab found at
the top right of your presentation
window or report the problem by typing
it into the answer question box located
on the far left of your screen this is
an educational webinar and thus offers
free continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education credit
tab located on the top right of your
presentation window and follow the
process for obtaining those credits I
now present today's speaker Cesar
Evaristo to learn more about dr.
Evaristo please visit the speaker
biography tab at the top of your screen
dr. every so welcome you can may now
begin your presentation
thank you for the introduction Susie I'd
like to welcome you all to this webinar
entitled every cell matters how to
maximize tumor micro-environment
analysis from limited spaceship samples
I will start by giving a short
introduction followed by identifying
some of the challenges faced when
conducting cancer research and how we
developed workflows to overcome those
challenges
I will then zoom in on some of those
workflows and detail some of the tools
we use for sample preparation magnetic
enrichment and analysis of the
populations of interest
the new system has the capacity to
eliminate tumors mutated antigens can be
released from tumor cells and introduced
induce an immune response in which dcs
will activate tumor specific t-cells
these t-cells then migrate through the
blood vessels into the tumor sites where
they recognize and kill the tumor cells
for the most part this is an effective
process however in every single cancer
patient at least one of these steps
failed immunotherapy has proven clinical
efficacy in tremendous potential in
multiple cancers but even patients who
experience clinical benefits from these
new agents often achieve only partial
responses such that additional work is
necessary to improve in your therapeutic
strategies
as this figure illustrates solid tumors
are complex tissues not only are they
comprised of proliferating tumor cells
that are supported by a plethora of
stromal cells that participate in
functions such as tissue remodeling and
new energy Genesis including many
different immune cells all these cell
populations are in constant
communication and influence each other's
activity function in phase
it's becoming increasingly clear that a
comprehensive analysis of the tumor
microenvironment is key to understand
the dynamics of the anti-tumor immune
response in our case we're interested in
phenotyping tumour cells fibroblasts
endothelial cells T cells B cells and
myeloid cells in sequencing tumor cell
mutations identifying new antigens and
tumor specific T and B cell phones
however to do this we are dependent on
the availability of tumor material this
brings us to the challenges routinely
faced when planning and performing
experiments in cancer research
most of the tumor samples from patients
we get wait between a 0.4 and 1 gram
after dissociation we get between 4 and
20 million live cells it turns out that
the reach the frequency of kills for
tumor infiltrating lymphocytes in the
tumor can be very reduced as illustrated
by this graph on the Left I calculated
in this table on the right the absolute
number of t b-- and myeloid cells that
we would obtain from a tumor with 20
million live cells containing the
average frequency of observed we that we
have observed among our samples we get 1
million T cells 200,000 b-cells in 1.8
million myeloid cells
however if we have to divide our
dissociated tissue in multiple samples
to individually analyze the different
cell populations we would lose a waste
the majority of ourselves
to prevent that we dissolve tools and
workflows that allow extracting the
maximum amount of information from
limited material while minimizing the
experimental time and workflow in
workload I will start by briefly
summarizing examples of our strategy and
then zoom in on specific portions of it
it all starts with the recession or
biopsy of the tumor sample the tissue is
stored and transported in tissue storage
solution upon arrival a small tissue
session is collected for future immuno
chemistry analysis the remainder is
associated and we take a small sample to
identify and quantify the new cell
populations
we can then isolate T cells using le cd4
cd8 to microbead kills these new
reagents can be released from the cell
surface after positive selection of the
cells of interest the isolated T cells
can then be used for phenotypic nodal
analysis undergo further magnetic
removal of dead cell in order to obtain
cells with high viability which is
required for downstream applications
such as single cell immune profiling and
RNA sequencing will even be used for
example for further magnetic subsets
enrichment followed by in vitro
expansion and further analysis the
negative freshen from the T cell
isolation can also be used the reallys
cd45 to microbeads kits can be used to
isolate to the rest of the tumor
infiltrating leukocytes after magnetic
release these cells can be further used
to isolate for example myeloid cells or
B cells which can then be used for
downstream applications such as
phenotype culture or sequencing the
negative fraction from the cd45
isolation can also be used for tumor
cell enrichment this is performed using
a negative selection kit and the tumor
cells can then be used for multiple
downstream applications such as
next-generation sequencing and new
epitope prediction in a typed culture or
establishment of patient-derived
xenograft model
finally in the positive fraction from
the tumor cell enrichment step other
cells of interest can be recovered such
as cancer associated fibroblasts which
can be phenotypes
the negative fraction from the cd45
isolation can also be used for tumor
cell enrichment this is performed using
a negative selection kit and the tumor
cells can then be used for multiple
downstream applications such as
next-generation sequencing a new epitope
prediction phenotype culture or
establishments of patient-derived
xenograft models
finally the positive fraction from the
tumor cell enrichment step other
self-interest can do recovered such as
cancer associated fiberglass which can
be phenotypes
I will focus the rest of this webinar on
the subset of these workflows additional
note any webinars detail the performance
and downstream applications of the other
workflows
I will do that by showcasing some of the
analysis we performed on one particular
sample from an ovarian cancer patient
most of the data going forward was
generated from a single tumor sample
additional supporting data used to
characterize the performance of
particular tools will be clearly
identified
in this particular experiment we were
contacted in the middle of the afternoon
with information that an ovarian
carcinoma sample has been rejected from
patients the tumor sample was stored in
max tissue storage solution and shipped
to us overnight this solution has been
developed to allow optimized storage of
fresh organ and tissue samples it has
been tested and validated on a variety
of human and mouse tissues including
tumors lung heart brain spleen skin
kidney and skeletal muscle the graph on
the left so the frequency of cells per
gram of tissue recovered after storage
in different solutions for 48 hours at 4
degrees or room temperature as compared
with the fresh tissue on the column on
the right
and this graph shows the viability of
the cells in the same conditions as you
can see tissues stored in max tissue
storage solution at 4 degrees maintain
original cellular yield and viability
even after 48 hours with no induction of
apoptosis or increase in necrosis in no
cell activation or influence on marker
expression
the next morning we used our automated
associate er in our optimized tumor
dissociation kits to generate a single
cell suspension using these tools
automated Association of multiple
samples can be done in parallel it
combines both mechanical and enzymatic
treatment for efficient Association
this means the disruption of
extracellular matrix and cell adhesion
components without destroying the
integrity of the cell membrane while
simultaneously preserving the cell
surface epidermis
the interest of optimized enzymatic
Association can be showcased in this
example just doing your mechanical
Association will result in the loss of
self populations which are closely
attached to the tumour cell such as
tumor reactive T cells using the tumor
association kits will enable the
identification of these rare cell
populations furthermore we do in health
control of the quality of the enzymes
used and the tumor dissociation kit was
optimized for epitope reservation we
tested over 200 epitopes the vast
majority of which was not affected by
our enzyme composition I'm not expecting
you to be able to read this but this
list of tested epitopes can be accessed
on our website
after dissociation we took a small
sample to identify and quantify the new
cell populations using our H caller you
know phenotyping kit
Here I am showing the plots with the
gating strategy after including dead
cells and doublet we gate on cd45
positive leukocytes from those we use
the morphology gate to exclude small
debris and large tumor cells we can then
identify cd14 positive macrophages and
from the cd14 low population we plus C
19 verses CD 3 to identify b-cells from
the non b-cell gates we plot cd16 CD 56
in the same channel against side scatter
to identify neutrophils and eosinophils
from the side scatter low gates we plot
city 16 in CD 56 against cd32 identify
NK cells t-cells and CD 3 positive CD 56
positive cells finally from the T cell
gate we plot cd4 versus cd8 to identify
our major T cell populations
then quantify the frequency of the major
leukocyte populations in the tumor and
it becomes quite obvious that the
frequency that each of the individual
populations is quite low because these
cells are so often found in low
frequencies we developed new reagents
for the magnetic isolation of T cells
specifically from the tumor based on the
newly released technology
briefly the Haley's technology relies on
recommend recombinant li engineered low
affinity antibody fragments that are
multi mirai's in the Rayleigh's complex
cells are labeled with these by
generated complexes in anti biotin
microbeads the target cells are then
retained on a column placed on a new
magnet while non target cells fall
through the target cells are then eluded
in the microbeads are removed resulting
in beat free cells that can be used for
second magnetic labeling in isolation
for certain applications the helis
complex can also be removed resulting in
label-free cell
using these new reagents we were
consistently able to quickly isolate
tumor infiltrating leukocytes with high
purity and directly use them for
analysis or because of the additional
flexibility provided by the Haley system
we have a world of possibilities for
isolation of specific populations we can
purify t-rex from tumors combining
really cd4 2 with C 25 microbeads we can
generate high viability tools for RNA
seek using dead cell removal kit after T
cell isolation we can isolate tumor
residence memory T cells isolated tumor
specific vs. by standard T cells we can
isolate untouched gamma delta T cells
and so on
you
we isolated T cells from our dissociated
ovarian carcinoma sample using LDC for
CDH till microbeads chips in the
addition to this we also have available
really cd4 cd8 n c d3 microbead gets
four chambers T cell and we will soon
also have the helis cd45 till micro beat
kit available
using these brand-new reagents we were
able to quickly isolate pills with high
purity on the top row you can see the
frequency of CD 3 positive cells among
live single lymphocyte sizes cells in
the bulk sample as compared to after
isolation on the bottom row we were able
to achieve over 92% purity of tumor
infiltrating T cells from our ovarian
carcinomas sample
after magnetic enrichment of our cells
of interest we are now ready for
analysis
this is done using a high affinity
antibodies in channelized
on the max punch a fully automated
faucet timer kept the affinity
antibodies are genetically engineered to
enhance reproducibility and eliminate
bias all antibodies have one Universal
igg1 isotype which reduces the
complexity of the experimental planning
in a mutated FCU region that eliminates
the FC receptor binding mediated
backgrounds
using magnetically isolated T cells from
the ovarian tumor sample greatly
facilitated both cytometry analysis
having highly enriched cells of interest
reduces the number of total events we
need to acquire for meaningful analysis
of rare subpopulations resulting in
shorter acquisition time reduced
background and cleaner populations in
this example we interrogated the
expression of p1 cd39 10 3 & 4 1 BB
among cd4 T cells on the top row in
among city stage T cells on the bottom
row in addition we were interested in
performing RNA seek in Union profiling T
and B cells infiltrating this tumor
sample
we try to preserve an alley code of the
dissociated tumor and at a later time
point we thought our sample it removed
the dead cells using the dead cell
removal kit we then use the really cd4
cd8 to microbeads to isolate T cells for
single cell TCR sequencing in RNA seek
from the negative fraction we isolated B
cells in plasma cells for single cell
VCR sequencing this way we could use the
majority of T cells for the T cell
analysis in the majority of B cells for
b-cell analysis
we used the 10x platform which can
generate up to 10,000 single cell gems
per sample so a direct effect of
magnetically isolating the cells of
interest is that we greatly increase the
frequency of single cell tt-rs in BC RS
on our sample as you can see in this
table
these graphs I am displaying in the
x-axis the 15 or 25 more represented
chrono types in T or B cells
respectively and in the y-axis the
number of cells that express that
particular chrono type in the isolated
sample as you can see we were able to
identify several prototypes that were
represented multiple times in the
isolated samples in contrast several of
those prototypes would have gone
unnoticed
when we analyzed the both samples for
example a clonal type that was present
in 20 HT cells in the isolated sample
was only present in three cells in the
bulk sample on the B cells we were able
to identify one prototype represented
120 cells from magnetically isolated be
saw but was only found in four cells in
the bulk sample these results highlights
the degree to which magnetic isolation
can improve the resolution of
single-cell RNA seek and immune
profiling
with this workflow we were able to
identify and quantify tumor infiltrating
immediate relations isolate multiple
cell populations for for downstream
analysis characterized phenotypically
the isolated population and increase the
resolution of single-cell RNA seek an
immune profiling of cells of interest
however in order to completely
characterize the tumor microenvironment
it may be useful to access the spatial
distribution of different cell
populations and their phenotypes in
order to do that before tumor
dissociation we collected a small tissue
section and use our Maxima platform
which allows the staining of hundreds of
markers in a single sample
it uses the principle of an iterative
staining process conducted by the maxima
imaging platform in a completely
automated manner briefly this platform
stained the sample with the first
specificity and acquires a fluorescence
microscope image the staining is then
erased
sample is staying - with a second
specificity and the second image is
collected this cycle can be repeated
hundreds of times in a fully automated
way
as an example I'm showing a section from
our initial ovarian cancer sample with a
region rich in tumor islets in the top
right corner characterized by expression
of F cam and T span aids in the stromal
region without tumor cell in the
following slides we will keep F cam
staining in red try to defy tumour cells
in the indicated map marker will be
displayed in white
looking at cd45 expression we can
appreciate that immune cells tend to
accumulate outside of the tumor area
we can locate the macrophages using cd14
expression for example td-30 h
identifies b-cells
plasma cells can be identified by c 138
expression
these three expression identifies
t-cells
majority are cd4 cells consistent with
our flow cytometry data but also we can
find our cd8 t-cells and we can further
characterize phenotypically the T cell
in this case with the expression of the
costumers co-stimulatory molecule C D 27
or cd28
one BB
I thought
but also markers that correlate with
tissue residents memory T cells like C
69 in C D 103
expressionist Democrat receptors can
also be assessed like cscl CXC r3
we can identify cells that Express PDL 1
for negatively regulating t-cell
activity and the expression of immune
checkpoints like ctla4 P 1 and 10 3
we can even identify which cells were
actively proliferating using ki67
staining in this case unfortunately this
indicates that tumor cells are the ones
proliferating in the sample
in summary I showed you here today new
workflows that allow the complete
characterization of the tumor
microenvironment these start with tissue
preservation during shipping with tissue
storage solution automated tissue
dissociation with optimizing somatic mix
in identification and quantification of
tumor infiltrating immune populations
by implementing magnetic enrichment
steps we are able to analyze multiple
distinct populations while minimizing
the loss of limited material and enhance
the phenotypic characterization of the
isolated self populations using the
newly released technology we can perform
consecutive enrichment of dedicated tool
box subpopulations
and have complete flexibility for
studying several cell populations from
just one sample in addition magnetic
enrichment results in increased
resolution of single-cell RNA seek and
immune profiling of cells of interest
finally with maximum imaging platform we
can study the spatial distribution of
different cell populations and their
phenotypes within the tumor
microenvironment using these workflows
it becomes feasible to fully embrace the
complexity of the tumor microenvironment
I would like to acknowledge my team in
all my colleagues at milky biotech that
made it possible to put together these
workflows as well as our collaborators
at the University of gutting in Bonn and
cologne for providing material in
testing our workflows off-site
thank you doctor Evaristo for your
presentation and a quick reminder for
our audience on how to submit questions
simply type them into the drop down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window labeled ask a
question and click that send button
dr. Evaristo will answer as many
questions as time permits so let's take
a look at our first incoming questions
from our audience members dr. every so
why are when would you recommend
choosing releasable microbeads instead
of regular
40 sell ice elations from human tumors
release micro beat chills were
specifically optimized for these
difficult issues for the fervor for the
tumors we do not have for this moment
regular microbeads for t cell isolation
from human tumors and the regular
microbeads that are available for PBMCs
they do not perform as well as the these
products specifically optimized for
tumor tissue sorry for c-45 for example
we do have regular microbeads optimize
for tumor the performance of both types
of product is a pretty comparable in
those cases and for if you if you're
interested in isolating cd45 positive
cells if you just need it depends on the
on the - room application that you're
interested in if you just need to
isolate lymphocytes for direct direct
phenotypic analysis by flow cytometry or
culture you can use either type of
reagents i personally personally might
favor the direct microbeads just because
the protocol is faster and simpler
however the helis microbeads give you
extra flexibility for more complex
downstream applications for example you
cannot isolate leukocytes with direct
cd45 microbeads
and then further separate macrophages
and b-cells because all leukocytes are
already magnetically labeled when
isolating T cells from human tumors I
personally personally really like the
flexibility that is given by how these
some some tumors are very very necrotic
and even after isolation the frequency
of dead cells is very high for some
functional assays for example and if the
cells were isolated with Halley's
technology I have the option to further
deplete the dead cells with regular
microbeads this option would no longer
be available so it really depends on
your downstream applications what you
need to do with the cell
thank you dr. Evaristo and you mentioned
magnetic isolation would minimize the
loss of material and you suggested
performing several consecutive isolation
steps in order to purify different cell
populations what is the recovery for
these isolation steps
so the recovery it depends on the
specific isolation the reagent they
usually range a range around the 80% but
of course it also depends on your
material it depends on the state of your
material how fibrotic it is so so with
with 80% with around 80% recovery even
if you had to do seven consecutive
isolations you would still be in a
better shape than if you were to divide
the initial sample in five for example
where you immediately with would have
only 20% of your cells of interest
available to you and of course it also
depends on on whether you are using
cells from the positive or negative
isolation steps
thank you and thank you to our audience
members for their questions coming in
dr. everybody so in your initial work
flow chart
you mentioned dead cell exclusion after
T cell isolation but when you describe
your work with ovarian cancer material
you depleted dead cells before T cell
isolation is there a difference so when
you're using if you're using a release
for the isolation of of your cells of
interest it doesn't make a big
difference you can either remove the
dead cells before or after if in this
case the we isolated we isolated T cells
with Hallie's but we isolated B cells
with direct microbeads in this case we
had to perform death or removal before
the isolation and honestly a if I if I
do if I remove the dead cells before the
first isolation then it's done and I
only have to do that
isolation step one if I did first the T
cell isolation were the individual cell
type isolations and then the deaths are
removal then I would have to do multiple
deaths or removal steps that's a reason
thank you and we have time for a couple
of more questions our next question from
an audience member is different types of
tumors have very different cellular
compositions have you used these
workflows with tumors other than ovarian
cancer
yes we have we we have used them in the
samples from ovarian cancer melanoma
lung cancer breast cancer pancreatic
cancer
[Music]
I think that we also used it in in some
inner graph models yeah
thank you and we have time for one more
question can your workflows be used to
isolate Carty cells from patients and
xenograph models how would you go about
doing that
ah that's actually a very interesting
application yes it could definitely be
used for that I would what were I would
suggest it if you have a marker a
specific marker for your party so if you
have a car t-cell detection reagents you
can start by isolating T cells from the
tumor using alleys you then would you
then would release the the magnetic
label or the full label and then you
could label your isolated T cells with
your car detection reagents with either
biotin elated tag or with a PE tag and
then you can use either anti biotin or
anti PE microbeads to further isolate
your party self
thank you so much for your presentation
today doctor are very so do you have any
final comments you'd like to provide for
the audience I would like to thank you
all for listening and for your questions
and thank you also City for moderating
this you're very welcome and thank you
again and thank you for your important
research I'd also like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions and I'd also
like to think elaborate and our sponsor
Milton E biotech for underwriting
today's educational webcast this webcast
can be viewed on demand and lab routes
will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share this email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time bye bye